When working with metahumans, there may be cases where we want to adjust our project render settings and lighting in order to get the best visual results.
Let's take a look at some of these settings and how they affect a metahuman in a level.
In the project settings, in the engine rendering section, the global illumination and reflection method setting will be set to Lumen by default,
and support hardware ray tracing will also be enabled by default in Engine versions 5.5 and later.
It is worth mentioning that in Engine versions 5.4 and later, ray tracing is no longer available as an option for reflection method,
as ray trace reflections are built into Lumen's reflection system.
For settings you may want to adjust, the first one is the Lumen ray lighting mode.
This setting allows us to control how Lumen reflections are lit.
We can adjust this in the project render settings or through a post-process volume that is placed in a level.
The second setting you may want to adjust is in the direct lighting section.
You can enable ray trace shadows here and this setting will be applied globally in a project.
Or you can enable this inside of each individual light.
Now, let's jump into Unreal Engine and take a look at how these render and light settings can change the appearance of a metahuman in a level.
In the Outliner, I have turned off the Key Light 1 and the Top Light to better see the effects some of these settings will have.
Let's begin by selecting the post-process volume.
Then, go to the Lumen Global Illumination settings.
Here, we can control the ray lighting mode.
As mentioned, this setting will allow Lumen to use hardware ray tracing and to control how the Lumen reflections are lit.
By changing this from surface cache to hit lighting, Lumen will calculate the overall lighting at the hit point.
If we change this to hit lighting for reflections, Lumen will calculate the lighting at the hit point, resulting in higher quality reflections but at the cost of performance.
Now, let's see how we can enable and disable ray trace shadows for individual lights.
I'm going to select Key Light 2 in the Outliner and in the Light search bar, I will search for ray trace.
Under the Advanced Light settings, we can enable or disable cast ray trace shadows for this light.
When we change this to Enabled, we can see the shadows are softer.
If we change this back to Disabled, we can see the shadows are hardened.
Let's leave this enabled.
Inside of individual light settings, we can also control the shadows of hair strands.
I'm going to search for Deep Shadow.
Over here, notice the appearance of the grooms.
Once we enable Deep Shadow, this light will cast high quality hair strand shadows and we can see the grooms have a bit more detail.
With this setting enabled, we can also use the Groom Asset Editor to fine tune the appearance of the strands even more.
I'm going to select our MetaHuman.
In the Details panel, I'm going to select the Eyebrows component and then go to the Groom Asset and open it.
In the Strands panel of the Groom Asset Editor, over here, we can check on Use Hair Ray Tracing Geometry.
This may not be as noticeable with the eyebrows, but enabling this will help improve the strand rendering quality for Groom Assets.
Over here, we can also adjust the hair shadow density.
If we set this to 1, this will increase the amount of shadows on the groom.
And if we set this to a lower value like 0.3, this will decrease the amount of shadows on the groom.
And this is especially helpful if you encounter flickering with hair shadows and transmission.
Now, let's do a quick review of what we just covered.
We just looked at a few different render and light settings we can adjust in a project when working with MetaHumans in a level.
Using a post-process volume, in the Lumen Global Illumination settings, we can control how Lumen Reflections are lit through the Ray Lighting Mode options.
When set to Surface Cache, Lumen will prioritize performance.
When set to Hit Lighting, Lumen will calculate the overall lighting at the hit point.
And when set to Hit Lighting for Reflections, Lumen will calculate lighting at the hit point, prioritizing the highest quality reflections.
Ray Trace shadows result in softer shadows, as opposed to harder shadows when disabled.
For this to work, support hardware ray tracing must be enabled in the project settings.
If we wish to have Ray Trace shadows affect our entire project, we can enable this in the project settings.
If we wish to have control over which lights cast Ray Trace shadows, we can do this in the individual light settings.
We can also control the quality of hair strand shadows inside of individual light settings.
By enabling Cast Deep Shadows in the Advanced Light Options, we can get high quality hair strand self-shadowing.
To improve the strands rendering quality, we can enable Use Hair Ray Tracing Geometry.
And we can also increase or decrease the amount of shadows on a groom by adjusting the hair shadow density.
We just finished going over how we can make adjustments to the various metahuman components and project render settings and the environment when working with metahumans in a level.
Now, let's wrap up by moving on to the final section of our course by going over some resources for you to use.
As you continue your training with metahumans in Unreal Engine.